- [Narrator] The population
P of T of bacteria
in a petry dish satisfies the logistic
differential equation.
The rate of change of
population with respect to time
is equal to two times the population times
the difference between six
and the population divided by 8000,
where T is measured in hours
and the initial population
is 700 bacteria.
What is the carrying
capacity of the population;
and what is the population's size
when it's growing the fastest?
So in order to even attempt
to answer these questions
at any point if you're inspired,
definitely pause the video
and try to answer it by yourself.
Let's just remind ourselves
what we're talking about
or what they're talking about
with the logistic differential equation
and the carrying capacity.
So in general a logistic
differential equation
is one where we seeing
the rate of change of,
and it's often referring to population,
so let's just stick with population.
So the rate of change of our
population with respect to time
is proportional to the
product of the population
and the difference between what's known
as the carrying capacity
and the population.
Now why is this a model
that you'll see a lot,
especially why is it useful
for studying things like populations.
When a population is small
the environment really isn't limiting it
and so assuming it starts
from some none zero value,
this thing grows, this
thing is not going to get
much smaller and so
our population is going
to a rate of change is going to increase.
And so let me just draw
a little graph here
to show the typical solution
to a logistic differential equation.
So this is our population, this is time,
so when our population is low,
let's say it's gonna start
from some non zero value,
if it was zero what would happen,
well then our rate of
change would just be zero
and our population would never
grow and that makes sense.
If you have no bunnies on your island
then there never will be
any bunnies on your island
but if you have a few
bunnies well initially,
their rate of change,
the rate of population is
gonna keep accelerating
as this thing grows, it's
but then at some point your
environment is going to
limit how many bunnies
for example or bacteria
can grow in your environment.
Because once the
population gets close to A,
this thing right over here
is going to approach zero
and its going to make our rate of change
smaller and smaller and smaller.
And so you can imagine
in the limiting case
as P gets very close to A,
you can imagine as T approaches infinity,
our rate of change is
going to approach zero.
So one way to think about it is,
our population would acemtote
towards the carrying capacity.
That is A right over here,
that is our carrying capacity.
So there's a couple of ways
of answering this first question; one way
is we can actually put our
logistic differential equation
in this form and then we can recognize
what the carrying capacity is.
The other way is to think
about, well what happens
as T approaches infinity.
As T approaches infinity,
this thing approaches zero
and so we can think from this
logistic differential equation
what P values would
make this thing be zero
based on this differential equation
or when this thing approaches zero,
what P values would this approach.
So let's do it both ways.
So one way, let me write it
in this form right over here,
so it's close, this is
six minus P over 8000,
can we make it in the form
where we just have some number
minus P.
Well if we multiply this times 8000
and then we divided this by 8000
we wouldn't be changing the
value of that expression
so let's do that.
If we divide this by 8000 you have
DP DT is equal to 2P over
8000 is P over 4000 times
and now let's multiply
this expression by 8000.
So six times 8000 is 48,000
minus P over 8000 times 8000
is minus P and there you have it.
We've written it down
to somewhat classic form
and we can see that the carrying capacity
is 48,000, I guess we say 48,000 bacteria.
So this thing right over here is 48,000.
Another way we could think about it is,
well the carrying capacity is what happens
as T approaches infinity.
So as T approaches infinity,
this thing right over here
approaches zero, you can
see the rate of change
approaches zero.
So when that approaches
zero what does P approach?
So we can just solve for
this; six minus P over 8000.
Well there's two situations, two Ps
for which our derivative is equal to zero.
There's one case when
this is equal to zero,
in which case our population is to zero
or the other case is when
this is equal to zero.
So let's do that; six minus
P over 8000 is equal to zero
or we could say P over
8000 is equal to six
and so we can say multiply
both sides by 8000,
P is equal to 48000.
Which is exactly what
we had right over there.
So now let's answer the second part.
What is the population's size
when it's growing the fastest?
So intuitively you can see
when that is right over here,
the rate of change is gonna grow
but then as we approach
the carrying capacity,
the rate of change is
gonna start slowing down.
So your maximum rate of change,
it's growing the fastest,
is right about there but how
do we figure out it exactly.
Well you could go back to the logistic
differential equation.
You can see that it's
really our rate of change
is a function, you could view it as
a function of our
population right over here.
And this is actually a
quadratic expression,
this is a concave downward
it would look like this,
if you were graphing rate
of change, let me do that,
if you were to graph rate of change,
DP DT as a function of population,
well when the population is
small, so when the population
is, say 700 or that's
where we're starting.
I'll just speak in generalities,
when your population is
small DPT, your rate is small
but then it increases and
then some point around there
the rate of change starts to
decrease and it approaches zero
as our population is approaching
the carrying capacity.
So this right over here for
example, would actually be
our carrying capacity.
What is this maximum point right over here
and there's a couple of
ways you could approach it
with calculus and even
algebra, we have many tools
for identifying this maximum point
which is really just a vertex
of this downward opening,
this concave downward parabola.
So let's just do that and
let's find this vertex
and the vertex is just
half way between the zeros
of this quadratic.
So let's find the P values
that make this equal to zero
which we actually just figured out,
the vertex is just gonna
be half way between that.
So when the population is zero
our rate of change is zero
when the population is A,
which we know is 48,000,
our rate of change is zero and
so our maximum rate of change
is gonna happen half way
between those two points
which is 24,000
So it is a population of 24,000.
When we got that by really just saying
well at one point does this quadratic,
quadratic is a function of P,
when does that hit a maximum point.
Well that's going to be
half way between the zeros,
the zeros happen when P equals
zero and P is equal to 48,000
so that's gonna happen when
the population is 24,000.
So this type of problem seems
very intimidating at first,
logistic differential equation,
how do I actually solve
this and then analyze it
but the key is to; one,
recognize a logistic
differential equation,
see what it's talking about
and then maybe think of this
in terms of our rate of change
as a function of our population.
And remember that the carrying
capacity is what happens
as T approaches infinity
and as T approaches infinity
our rate of change approaches zero.
And so if that's approaching zero,
what must our population be approaching.